on va parler de cette info on va revenir
sur cette fameuse BD Tintin au Congo qui
est au cœur de polémique depuis
plusieurs années accusé de véhiculer des
stéréotypes des clichés sur les
Africains désormais elle a une nouvelle
couverture et surtout une préface pour
expliquer je cite le contexte
colonialiste al comprenez-vous cette
décision pour la préface et la nouvelle
couverture de Tintin Congo c'est notre
premier première question du soir
[Musique]
regardez ces derniers jours une bande
dessinée est au cœur de l'actualité
Tintin au Congo Tintin au Congo Tintin
au Congo sorti pour la première fois en
1930 Tintin au Congo vient de
réapparaître dans sa version originale
et si l'auteur c'était par le passé
défendu d'être raciste si on prend tout
toutes les album il y a des des des
méchants à au teint basané mais il y a
des méchants au teint blanc aussi Tintin
au Congo continuait de choquer écrite à
l'époque coloniale l'abd était accusé de
glorifier la colonisation alors republ
ié dans sa version originale et en
couleur la couverture a cette fois été
changée et une préface a été ajoutée
pour recontextualiser une démarche dont
certains se réjouissent aujourd'hui
cette préface est importante parce
qu'elle aPAE alors la bande dessinée
Tintin au Congo aura maintenant une
nouvelle couverture et une préface pour
ne plus choquer comprenez-vous cette
décision c'est le minimum mais il
fallait aller plus loin qui vous a donné
la parole vos
yeux bravo minimum mais il fallait aller
plus loin il fallait brûler cette bande
dessinée et regardez la couverture on
enlève le noir alors c'est très bien
d'enlever l'enfant noir avec le
stéréotype du noir les grosses lèvres et
cetera et à la place on met un lion et
je trouve que c'est terrible parce que
on le rend invisible le noir parce qu'on
'ose pas donc c'est hypocrite on
regardez on met un lion à la vous voyez
comme si on le Gom on le gomme de
l'istoire comment peut représenter un
noir dans une BD sans être caricaturel
ou discriminant on ne doit pas la
représenter on doit la mettre au feu
cette bande desessiné
si tu fais ça tu mets la moitié des
bouquins au feu à ce momentl tu mets la
moitié des films au feu tu mets la
moitié des livre au feu tu dist tri
nimporte c'est pas c'est pas en effaçant
l'histoire qu'on va effacer le passé
colonialiste
progress dans les nouveaux écrits oui tu
as raison dans les nouveaux écrits oui
mais le passé c'est le passé leseses ont
ét
éc passé c'est le passé mais il y a qu'à
toi que je peux me confiller si je
deviens parano des fois non mais c'est
bon Pat il a dit un truc fou ce ce qui
m' triste tu veux bien faire c'est que
tu par ça partle d'un bon sentiment mais
malheureusement tu tapes à côté à chaque
fois c'est complètement débile ce que tu
dis il y a eu 250 millions de d'albums
vendus de Tintin de Tintin Tintin Congo
c'est celui qui a le plus marché donc il
y a des centaines de millions de
racistes en France qui se gavent et qui
devien pres et qui deviennent presque
raciste en lisant ttintin Congo je
dirais deuxièmement que que tu dis
laisse-moi terminer laisse terminer tu
fais c'est criminel parce que c'est
criminel d'effacer les traces du crime
parce en effaçant les traces d'une
époque coloniale qui a été très
maladroitement et dramatiquement exprimé
dans inttin Congo et ben du coup ça ça
ça contribue à faire disparaître le
colonialisme que tu combats il faut
contraire laisser les traces pour
pouvoir s'insurger et montrer aux jeunes
générations par qui le la band dessinée
est un biais d'entrée facile que voilà
ce que c'était le colonialisme et
dernièrement parceè je sens tu comprends
ce que tu dis je pense que je pense que
Gill me comprends très bien je vois son
regard et troisièmement tu qui défend le
plus tatin au Congo c'est les Congolais
voilà mais oui mais bosse tes dossiers
avant de venir ici au Congo mais moi
j'ai bossé un tu as été au Congo oui j
suis allé mais ça au car all au Congo
toi oui alors ça
t'emmerde alli au
Congo all au
Congo Jama allé au Congo les Congolais
défendent inttin au Congo mais tu es
complètement malade tu vois tu vois
malheureus
malement tu B pas ça a déjà été ça déjà
été suspendu une fois au 20e siècle la
Paron de to qui a plid international au
gong qui a plidé au niveau international
pour la réapparition que ça
soit congolais dans le principal journé
là-bas le principal
journaléé j'ai la écrit en une du
magazine
congolais il y a une chose que les
Blancs qui avent arrêté la circulation
de Tintin Congo n'ont pas compris C
chose la voici si certaines images
caricaturales du peuple congolais donné
par Tintin Congo font sourire les blancs
elles font elles font rire franchement
les Congolais parce que les Congolais
ils trouvent matière à se moquer de
l'homme blanc qui voyit comme cela voilà
eux ils sont plus intelligents prochaine
fois ne lis pas excuse-moi j'ai pe le dé
tu as compris ce qu'il a dit rien du
tout mais j'ai rien compris des
Congolais mais non mais c'est fou cette
bande destinée est honteuse JeanMichel
mais il est sympa on l' supprimer
géraline il un truc fou g Gill verd non
mais c'est bizarre parce que j'ai dit
comme toi mais quand je t'écoute j'ai
envie de dire exactement le contraire
c'est quand même tuas un talent
particulier quand même Mo j'ai envie de
twist en fait c'est pour la culture et
moi je suis pour l'explain culture et je
trouve qu'effectivement la préface qui
fait de la pédagogie qui contextualise
elle est nulle elle est nulle la préface
parlons-en de la préface je trouve que
c'est très intéressant parce que
effectivement comme l'a dit Jean-Michel
mer avec certes une lecture un peu un
peu compliquée mais malgré tout très
très intéressante merci il va écrire à
briit Macron lui aussi ilait pas de prof
en fait si on efface en fait on peut
reproduire on peut reproduire l'horreur
et l'abomination et en revanche moi je
j'aimerais bien que tu m'expliques parce
que tu me dis le scandale dans cette
nouvelle nouvelle couverture c'est qu'en
fait ils ont effacé l'homme noir et
paradoxalement tu me dis mais dans la
première l'homme noir était de était
fait effectivement terrible et je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec toi et elle
est scandaleuse de manière caricaturale
donc comment a-t-on le droit selon le G
Verdez comment on a le droit d'illustrer
dans une BD une personne C et ben on
illustre pas dans Tintin au Congo c'est
pour ça qu'il faut la brûler voilà
c'est on a droit de mettre un noir dans
Tintin non mais comment comment
représente les dessins 1930 ne sont pas
les dessins
d'jourdhui es toujours dans le toujours
dans la merde 93 % qui me comprennent
pas
cette
aristocrate et vous avez vuens en
parlant de chaîne de télé euh retour sur
l'édition salée de France Télévision
festival de can France Télévision est
allé au Festival de Cannes et il y a une
énorme rigolade parce qu'il y a un blog
l'association de défense de
l'audiovisuel public qui a publié la
facture des frais d'hébergement de
plusieurs dirigeants de France-
télévision pendant le festival elle
s'est lévrée à plus de 112000 €
apparemment il y avait un bon miniar euh
regardz et c'est payé donc euh c'est
vous qui avez payé hein si vous nous
regardez 112000 € euh tu vas nous dire
to tuas tuas enquêté oui bah dis-nous
alors en fait ce qui est très étrange
c'est que cette les copies des factures
ont été envoyé à plusieurs personnes
dans Paris dont moi il y a un mois ah
ouais dont des syndicalistes 112123 €
entre le 13 mai et le 28 mai c'est ils
étaient au majestique à can ouais avec
des chambres qui vont de 1200 à 1800 €
la nuit pour celle qui pendant festival
de Cann et ce qui laisse à penser que
les personnes qui ont voulu envoyer ces
ces factures vou que on découvre et
qu'on enquête pourquoi euh à la fois
pourquoi cette somme mais aussi
peut-être parce qu'il y a une une
affaire de corruption derrière ou
pourquoi euh c'est je parle juste d'une
suspicion pour le moment parce que en
fait sur la facture on s'aperçoit que il
y a des hauts dirigeants de France
Télévision mais qu'il y a aussi des
producteurs d'une société privée en en
l'occurrence brut qui figure sur cette
facture et toute la question est de
savoir si ça a été payé avec l'argent du
service public évidemment France
télévision via la lettre A a répondu que
de toute façon même si ça a été payé par
l'agence de voyage de France Télévision
qui a bien réglé toute la note 112000 €
en tous les cas la société de production
en question va rembourser France
Télévision de sa partie à elle voilà
mais bon ça émeut quand même un certain
nombre de syndicalistes qui souhaiterait
essayer d'en savoir un peu pluser partie
à elle maintenant ou parce que c'est
découvert ver maintenant c'est juste
parce qu'ils ont étéés bah oui voilà ils
avent pas remboursé avant on n'a pas la
précision mais en tous les cas qui nous
est dit par France Télévision c'est que
la société de prod va va va prendre sa
part et va rembourser aux alentours de
30000 € ce qui lui revient à
elle de de voir venir ouis puisque sur
la facture tu as à la fois des haut
dirigeants de france télé et en même
temps des responsables de cette société
il faut savoir que cette société c'est
elle qui a en charge la couverture du
festival de Cann donc évidemment qu'il
soit à Cann c'est pas étonnant un
scandale ouais pas un scandale ils ont
pas un budget attribué normalement sur
leur déplacement non ce qui est sûr
c'est que d'un point de vue moral que
tout le monde se retrouve sur la même
facture c'est un peu bizarre donc c'est
pour ça que les des représentants
syndicaux veulent essayer d'en savoir un
petit peu plus là-dessus mais ça veut
pas forcément dire que il y a mal faaçon
ou queil y a une affaire de corruption
derrière évidemmentci merci merci de de
le rappeler en plus je les aime bien en
plus c'est des potes c'est brut de pomme
non le B c'est brut d'accord